how are you
uh i'm great how are you i'm a little
hungover i'm just kidding
that's fine thank you so much for
getting up early uh i'm a huge fan
of the office and your work on the show
i'm curious i mean one of the great
things about
the office is you know after michael
left
kind of the revolving door of the
different bosses and i'm curious from
your perspective
you know meredith seems to be a little
easygoing who do you think was her
favorite boss during that entire time
i'm gonna say uh um d'angelo vickers
uh played by um uh will ferrell
that that makes sense that checks out uh
season two is really kind of where
meredith starts to get fleshed out a bit
and i was kind of curious how that
worked from your perspective were you
talking to the writers were they asking
you
questions or was it just kind of like
seeing stuff pop up in the script that
like oh okay the character's going this
direction now
it was more like seeing stuff pop up in
the script i um
i didn't have a lot of conversations in
uh um for
a number of years um which was fine with
me it's it's like um we had the best
writers in tv and i i knew it right away
so it's sort of like
having mario andretti driving and then
you know you don't want to
grab the keys or tell him how to do his
job
the car was going in the right direction
yes that's fair
uh i mean you mentioned you knew right
away that the show was special
and that's kind of one of the things i
wanted to ask is the show now is huge
it's
everywhere but a lot of people don't
know that first season was a little like
ratings wise it was on the bubble it
wasn't sure if it was going to get
renewed
when did you know that the show was
special and then when did you know that
the show was a hit
well we had shot um the first season and
i still was working in a restaurant in
beverly hills so i was nervous about
the transformation you know just because
you just don't know and i'm older and
i've had a lot of like
this is it and it wasn't so um but i
remember
greg daniels invited me down to the
editing bay when they were finishing up
some of the episodes and i sat there and
i i knew it was going to be good but it
was even better than i
expected uh and i had known steve corel
for years from second city before that
uh
and uh i just you know i mean it was
it was a perfect storm because of 40
year old virgin
coming out during you know uh right
before
our second season so it was just it was
perfect timing it was a
it was like a total slow and steady wins
the race if you come out of the cannon
too big
you're screwed
[Laughter]
um my final question for you i'm running
out of time uh one of the things the
show is great with is call backs
um from the teapot to even mare to the
sun who comes back
uh as the stripper at the end what's
your favorite callback from
the run of the show um oh my gosh well
i'm gonna have to say jakey because i i
that spencer day goes i mean what a
crazy
uh thing to do to a young kid and then
have him grow up and then become
uh angela's uh stripper graham at her
bachelor party
bachelorette party i mean it's crazy
it's so lovely and and wonderful and and
i love how
devoted the fans are and how much
they're paying attention all the time
did you have a heads up that that was
happening or was that a surprise at the
table read when you got the script
it was a surprise i have a big mouth so
they didn't tell me much ahead of time
smart great thank you so much for your
time congratulations on everything
thank you so much take care